[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
تجددوا لشبكات وسمعوا اصوات انفجارات في
وسط الخرطوم رغم الهدنه الطويله
عشيه احتفالات يوم النصر روسيا تكثف
ضرباتها على اوكرانيا وتفرض اجراءات امنيه
مشدده في الداخل
الصين تهدد الاتحاد الاوروبي بعواقب اذا
فرضت عقوبات على شركات تابعه لها بحجه دعم
روسيا
[تصفيق]
توتر واشتباكات واعتقالات في الحملات
الانتخابيه بين انصار اردوغان والمعارضه
اذا مشاهدينا كما اسلفنا تجددت الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
وذلك في مناطق عده بالخرطوم ارتفعت اعمده
الدخان في العاصمه في وقت يجتمع به ممثلين
عن الجيش والدعم في جده لبحث وقف اطلاق
النار وفتح ممرات انسانيه وسبل لانهاء
الازمه كان مراسل العربيه افاد باشتباكات
جرت صباح اليوم في ام درمان والخرطوم
وسماع اصوات مضادات في وقت حلقت به
الطائرات بسماء العاصمه
على كل المشاهدين هذه الصور التي نشاهدها
الان صور مباشره من قلب العاصمه الخرطومه
الدخان لازال يتصاعد بعد تجدد الاشتباكات
كما ذكرنا في العاصمه وطبعا توتر اضافه
الى اشتباكات كانت قد سبقتها هذا الصباح
هذه
الشباكات تاتي في وقت يستمر فيه ممثلون عن
الطرفين المكونين العسكريين
تفاوض في جده للمحاوله للوصول الى اتفاقات
للتهدئه والوصول الى حل سلمي وطبعا هذه
الاشتباكات التي عادت الان الى الخرطوم
تعود طبعا في وقت هناك هدنه هدنه من
المفترض من انها الاطول منذ بدء الصراع
بين المكونين العسكريين
[موسيقى]
هذا وبحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان في اتصال هاتفي بحث الاوضاع
في الخرطوم مع مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بحسب وكاله
الانباء السعوديه فقد ناقش الاتصال
مستجدات المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
الخاصه بالسودان والتي تهدف لتهدئه او
تهيئه الارضيه اللازمه للحوار من اجل خفض
مستوى التوترات
اذا رغم هذه المفاوضات الجاريه في جده بين
ممثلين من الجيش وايضا الدعم السريع دخلت
المواجهات المستمره بين طرفي الصراع
الاسبوع الرابع والصمخاوف من ان تتخذ
الاشتباكات نقطه العوده
اسبوع رابع ينتصف من مواجهه السودان الذي
يمضي في طريق العوده نحو 500 مدنيين على
الاقل ذهبوا ضحيه النزاع المسلح فضلا عن
الاف المصابين واعداد اكبر للنازحين هنا
في جده تستمر المحادثه التمهيديه بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه الخارجيه
السعوديه اكدت ان طرفي النزاع اعرب عن
تحملهما مسؤوليه وصول المساعده الانسانيه
العاجله واستعاده الخدمات الضروريه في
السودان كما شرع الطرفان في مراجعه اعلان
الالتزام بحمايه المدنيين وتيسير واحترام
العمل الانساني
وتسعى محادثات جده الى وضع جدول زمني
لمفاوضات موسعه للوصول لوقف دائم للاعمال
القتاليه كما دعت الرياض و واشنطن طرفي
النزاع في السودان الى احترام وقف اطلاق
النار القائم حاليا والامتناع عن القيام
باي افعال استفزازيه تؤثر على سير
المحادثات
محادثات في جده واجتماع عربي طارئ في
القاهره نتج عنه انشاء لجنه اتصال عربيه
لوقف النار في السودان تتكون من وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ونظره المصري والامين
العام للجامعه العربيه
جهود سياسيه للتهدئه تقابلها تحركات
انسانيه وحملات اجلاء مستمره تبنتها
السعوديه اخرها تقديم مساعدات انسانيه
متنوعه بقيمه 100 مليون دولار واطلاق حمله
شعبيه لمسانده الشعب السوداني
شيبه اهلا بك عمار اذا
المعلومات الاشتباكات كانت في الصباح
توقفت وكان هناك ربما نوع من الهدوء
النسبي ما الذي حدث وهل لا زالت مستمره
حتى الان اين تتركز
كانت الاشتباكات منذ صباح اليوم ربما
خفيفه لم تكن بالشكل الذي كانت عليه في
الايام الماضيه ولكن قبل لحظات كنا نستمع
بشكل واضح ومباشر لاصوات انفجارات
ومدفعيه ثقيله ما بين الجانبين في منطقه
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم اي بالتحديد منطقه
السوق العربي وما زلنا نشاهد ونتابع تصاعد
اعمده الدخان من تلك المناطق وايضا كذلك
كان هنالك طلعات لطيران الجو قبل دقائق من
الان ربما استهدفت اهدافا على الارض في
منطقه السوق العربي وفي منطقه القصر
الرئاسي كل هذه الاشتباكات عدد بعد هدوء
نسبي كان او كنا نشهده طوال فتره بدايه
النهار ولكن الان ربما عاده الاشتباكات من
جديد خاصه وان طائرات الاستطلاع التي تاتي
اولا من ثم تعود الطائرات المقاتله لتنفيذ
الاهداف بعد توزيع الاحداثيات يبدو انها
عدد من جديد ونستمع الى صوتها بعد
مر تلوى المره ربما سؤال لانه عاده لم تكن
فيها اشتباكات عاده ما كنا نتحدث عن القصر
الجمهور الرئاسي وايضا عن بعض المناطق
المحدده هل تغيرت رقعه الاشتباكات او لا
زالت محصوره في تلك المناطق
نعم هي ما زالت محصوره في تلك المناطق
باعتبار انها مناطق استراتيجيه وباعتبار
ان هنالك تفاوض والجميع يحاول ان يحسن من
موقفه على الارض باعتبار ان ايضا هذه
المناطق حيويه وتؤثر جدا في صنع القرار
بشكل واضح وربما تشل الدوله من كثير من
القرارات ومع عمليه التفاوض يحاول كل طرف
ان يحاول ان يحسن من هذا الموقف التفاوضي
باعتبار انه يضع يده على مكان معين ذو
حيويه وذو استراتيجيه من خلال مؤسسات ومقر
الدوله وهذا ربما جعل كثير جدا من محاوله
الجيش لمحاوله تطويق ومحاوله خنق وتدعم
السرقه السريع المتواجده في عدد من
المواقع الاستراتيجيه كما قصر الجمهوري
ومنطقه السوق العربي وعدد من المناطق في
مدينه ام درمان ومدينه
عمار بمعنى اخر هل نتلمس نوع من التغير في
خارطه المواجهات الموجوده او من يسيطر على
ماذا
بحسب بيان الجيش الذي كان بالامس اشار فيه
لان الموقف العمليات مستقر وكلمه مستقر
هنا ربما لا تعني التقدم ولا تعني التاخر
باعتبار ان الوضع كما هو عليه منذ عده
ايام وربما تتغير المعركه باعتبار انها
حرب شوارع حرب كروه فر في عدد من المناطق
اما المناطق الاستراتيجيه ما زالت كما هي
يتحدث الجيش عن محاوله للدخول وتتحدث قوات
الدعم السريعه انها ما زالت تحكم السيطره
على ذلك البيانات تؤكد عدد من النقاط من
ضمنها بان الموقف مستقر مستقر اي بمعنى
ليس هنالك تقدم او تاخر هل يمكن لنا ان
نحرك الكاميرا قليلا عمار ربما لنشاهد
السماء خاصه بانك ذكرت بانه كان هناك سماع
لصوت الطيران يحلق في سماء الخرطوم
وبالمقابل بينما نقوم بهذه الخطوه تحدثنا
بعض الشيء عن الوضع المعيشي وايضا الصحي
نعم يعني في الجانب الاخر يمكن الكاميرا
ان تلتقط هذه المشاهد مشاهد تصاعد اعمده
الدخان من وسط العاصمه الخرطوم كما
نتابعها من هنا ولكن في الوضع المعيشي كنا
في جوله قبل قليل في عدد من الاحيان
القريبه بمنطقه شرق الخرطوم تبدو الحياه
صعبه جدا هنالك كثير جدا من المطالب
للمواطنين بان يتم تغيير الوضع الراهن
بعكس ان يتكيفوا مع هذه الاوضاع هم لا
يريدون التكيف مع وضع الحرب باعتبارها من
اصعب الاوضاع على المواطنين
باعتبار ان الدواء والغذاء والماء
والكهرباء المتطلبات الاساسيه للحياه هي
تنعدم وتنقطع ومن ثم هنالك ندرك كبيره جدا
في عدد من المواد الغذائيه كالدقيق والزيت
او عدد من المدخلات على مستوى
الاسره السودانيه كثير جدا من المطالبات
ميسونه ايضا تشير بشكل واضح الى ضروره وقف
الحرب باعتبار ان مجتمع العاصمه الخر هو
عدد من الولايات ايضا لم تتعود على حرب
طويله المغرب بهذه المده الزمنيه مما اثرت
على اشياء كثيره في حياتهم اليوميه حتى
على المستوى الطبي والمستوى الغذائي
والمستوى
الاقتصادي وتعلمين ان البنوك لا تعمل منذ
عمر منذ اليوم الاول لعمليات النزوح هربا
الاقتتال الدائر من الخرطوم عمار جعل هذا
ممكنا صحيح شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا مع استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع تتزايد عمليات النزوح هربا
من الاقتتال فعلى الحدود السودانيه
المصريه ينتظر العشرات من السودانيين من
بينهم النساء من بينهم ايضا اطفال في
مدينه وادي للعبور الى مصر فمع اغلاق مطار
الخرطوم هرب عشرات الالاف برا الى مناطق
اكثر امنا خارج العاصمه وعبر حدود البلاد
تشير الارقام الحكوميه الى ان ما لا يقل
عن 64 الفا عبروا الحدود المصريه والتي
تستضيف طبعا القاهره الصديد بالفعل ما
يقدر باربعه ملايين سوداني اصلا ولتحقيق
ذلك يتكدس السودانيون في حافلات وشاحنات
ويدفع كل منهم ما يصل الى 500 دولار
للانتقالي الى موقعين حدوديين هما ارقين
الى الغرب من بحيره النوبه وقسطل شمالي
وادي حلفا ثم الى مصر
يعني باي حاجه مت فلوس يعني ممكن السرير
في اليوم بكون سوداني
معانا اسرتنا وقاطعين مصاريف خالص وقاعدين
هنا هنا في الحديقه زي ما انت شايفه
الدنيا برد
والعيال ما عندهم مصاريف وانا غير كذا انا
باخد انسولين يعني الليله ثلاثه يوم انا
ما اخذتهم سليم ما في قروش عشان انا اشتري
انا خليت هناك اموالي وحالتي كلها في
الخرطوم وشغليه الخرطوم للمدرسه هنا ما في
اي مشكله المشكله الوحيده هي
ممتلي
وحتى في ناس عرضوا مبادره شنو يدفعوا مثلا
الناس تجمع من بعض على اساس انه
بيستحق تاشيره
فراح وقدم
بالتاشيره ولغايه اليوم احنا ما لاقيين
يعني اجابه
هذا ويواجه الالاف من العالقين في مطار في
الوجبه جنوب السودان اوضاع انسانيه قاسيه
شهد المطار التكدسا للفارين فيما اشتكى
غالبيتهم من انعدام المواد الاساسيه من
مياه او غذاء
هنا في مطار فلوج الجنوبي السودان يفترش
الالاف من الفارين من الاشتباكات في
السودان الارض
الحزن والسخط يبدوان على وجوههم
حيث يشتكون من المعامله السيئه من
القائمين على امر طرحيلهم
بعضهم وصف الوضع بالموت البطيء دم البطيء
بلدك
تتحال فوقه وتتبهدل فيه ما احسن شروط
تتحالف البلد ما بلدك الاوضاع الانسانيه
والمعيشيه تبدو سيئه للغايه
حيث يتعرض غالبيتهم الى ساعه الشمس
الحارقه واحيانا يعانون من حصول الامطار
ولسان حالهم يقول
رحلون من هنا قبل ان نموت
الرساله بتاعنا بس يعني
طريقه بس يصفرونا برا من هنا لانه هنا ده
ما في مويه اكل ما في يعني ناس قاعدين هنا
متجهزين وكده ناس تعبانين حتى تشوفوا
شوفوا صغير مثلا الناس كلهم
هكذا يبدو الوضع في مطار الفلوجه حيث
افترش الجميع الارض وعيونهم تراقب اي
طائره تحبط على هذا المدرج
مسؤول الاقاثه اعترفوا بان هناك تقصيرا هو
تجاوزات حدثت في مطارف اللج
وان السلطات الحكوميه والمدنيه ستعمل
جاهده على معالجه الامر
بتوفير الطعام وتكثيف الرحلات الى جباه
الشركان لكن ما جابوا حاجه تانيه حاجه
بتقول لوزير الوجه لمنظمات عشان اجيب
العقل للنسبه للنازل قاعدين في المطاعم
هنا اذا هي معاناه اخرى تواجه الالاف من
الفارينه من اصوات الرصاص والعالقين في
هذا المطار فاذا لم تسارع السلطات المعنيه
بطرحيلهم
فان الاوضاع مرشحه للاسوء
ميبيورشيللو العربيه مطار فلوج جنوب
السودان
[موسيقى]
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يلغي حفلا له في اسرائيل
بسبب مشاركه وزير الامن القومي اتمرنديفير
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نكمل من موسكو
حيث انهت روسيا الاستعدادات الاخيره قبيل
الاحتفال بيوم النصر واستمر خوف امنيه
طبعا متزايده موسكو ستحتفل غدا بعطله يوم
النصر حيث هزيمه المانيا في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ستقام الاحتفالات
التقليديه في الميدان الاحمر وسط اجراءات
امنيه مشدده موسكو الغت الاحتفالات في سته
اقاليم تقعوا ضمن 400 ميل من الحدود
الروسيه طبعا خوفا من تكرار هجمات وقعت
اخيرا بمسيارات داخل البلاد بالاضافه
لاستهداف الكرملين
في المقابل اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني ان
اوكرانيا ستتخلى عن احياء ذكرى الانتصار
على المانيا في الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
التاسع من ما يوافقا للتقليد السوفيتي
والروسي اضاف انه سيقدم الى البرلمان
مشروع قانون يعلن الثامن من مايو يوم
الذكرى والنصر على النازيه بحسب تعبيره
وتحتفل الدول الغربيه بذكرى استسلام
المانيا في الثامن من مايو لكن موسكو
تحتفل دائما بهذه الذكرى في التاسع من
الشهر نفسه بسبب فارق التوقيت
لن نسمح بالاستيلاء على الانتصار المشتركي
لشعوب التحالف المناهض الهتلر ولن نسمح
باكاذيب كان النصر كان يمكن ان يتم دون
مشاركه اي دوله او شعب دمرنا الشر معا مثل
ما نواجه الان شرا مشابها
المزيد معنا من موسكو شاشكوف المحلل
العسكري الروسي اهلا بك سيد بدايه قراءه
عسكريه بالمشهد اليوم والاستهداف لبعض
المناطق في كييف هل من فوائد عسكريه لذلك
السلام عليكم
فعلا
وجهت القوى الجويه الروسيه والبحريه
والقوات البريه اليوم
حزمه من الضربات الصاروخيه على مختلف
مناطق اوكرانيا وخصوصا على اماكن
التجمع القوات الاوكرانيه والمستودعات
وغيرها من الاهداف العسكريه تحسبا من شان
الهجوم المضاده الذي تم اعلان اعلانه
رسميا في كيف
مسبقا بطبيعه الحال لهجوم المضاد هذا قريب
جدا
وربما لا يبعدنا عن موعده الا ساعات
ومثل ما ذكرتهم غدا في روسيا عيد كبير عيد
عظيم جدا
يوم النصر النصر
يسمح لي انا بهمني اعرف الفوائد العسك ريه
من وراء هذه الضربه لانه بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا الضربات استهدفت مباني سكنيه
وبحسب التصريحات من هناك فقد تم اسقاط كل
المسيرات والاستهدافات كانت بسبب الشظايا
سقوط هذه الطائرات المسيره
طبعا الكلام هذا مبني مبني على تصريحات
كيف وكيف
دائما تقول ان الجيش الروسي لا يواجه
ضربته الا على المستشفيات والمدارس
والكنائس والاهداف البدنيه والمجمعات
السكنيه
والدفاعات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من اسقاط كل
الصواريخ المجنحه والمسيرات الروسيه حتى
مرات يزيد عدد الطائرات التي تمكن من
نسختها على عدد التيارات التي تم اطلاقها
الكلام هذا لا جديد فيه كما لا جديد في ان
تصريحات الرئيسكي والاداره الاوكرانيه
تقول ان النصر قريب
الجيش الاوكراني سوف يستطيع من اعاده
السيطره على كل الاراضي المفقوده والى
اخره هذا كله كلام دعائي كلام اعلامي رامي
الى رفع المعنويات والاساس له اطلاقا اذا
نظرنا الى ما يجري ميدانيه
الى ما يحدث بحسب رؤيتك لماذا الغاء عدد
من الاحتفالات بالقرب من الحدود
الاوكرانيه مما تخافه روسيا بهذا الاطار
بالفعل تم الغاء
العرض العسكريه المكرس لهذه
الذكرى
القديسه في قاعده
البحريه في
شبه جزيره القرم تحسبا لتوجيه الضربات
المكثفه على اماكن التجمع على سكان
المدنيين اثناء الاحتفالات نفس الشيء
ينتابك على
الاجراءات الامانيه المكثفه التي لقد تم
اجراء
في غيرها من المناطق الروسيه
لا يمكن الاستبعاد عن ان عن عن
محاولات وتحديات واعتداءات مثل هذه
يوم الغد بما فيها
موسكو وغيرها من
الاهداف الحساسه يعني من ماسكو وسرجياي
شاشكوف المحلل العسكري الروسي شكرا جزيلا
لك
بتزمر مع احتفالات يوم النصر شنت روسيا
اذا اكبر موجه من الضربات بالطائرات
المسيره على اوكرانيا وذلك منذ شهور قال
رئيس بلديه كييف ان روسيا اطلقت 60 طائره
مسيره على اهداف اوكرانيه منها 36 هدفا
داخل العاصمه وقد تم اسقاط كل المسيرات
رئيس بلديه كياب اكد ان حطام هذه المسيرات
اصابه عدد من المباني من بينها مباني
سكنيه مما ادى الى اصابه خمسه اشخاص على
الاقل هذا وقد شب حريق في مستودع مواد
غذائيه بمدينه اوديسا المطله على البحر
الاسود حيث افاد مسؤولون بان ثلاثه اشخاص
قد اصيبوا طبعا يعتبر هذا اكبر عدد
للطائرات المسيره في موجه من هجمات روسيا
على الاطلاق اذا فسفت هجماتها مجددا منذ
عشره ايام بعد فتره هدوء منذ اوائل مارس
الماضيه
المزيد معنا من كييف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بك حذيفه وضيفي قبل قليل كان
يقول بانه الاستهدافات كانت ناجحه عسكريا
اذا مصحه تعبير هل لدينا رصد اين استهدفت
هذه الطائرات او بقاياها اذا ما امنا
بالروايه الاوكرانيه ايضا في ذلك هل فعلا
مبالا سكنيه فقط ام انه هناك مواقع عسكريه
دقيقه تم استهدافها
مساء الخير في الحقيقه المبنى السكني الذي
اصيب هو طبعا الضربه كانت في الليل
والمبنى السكني الذي اصيب انا اسكن جواره
بالضبط يعني
رايته الطائره وهي تسقط الله يسلمك يعني
انا رايت بعيني الطائره او حطام الطائره
وهو يسقط على هذا المنزل وهذا المنزل حتى
نفسه لم يتضرر بشكل كبير تضرر من الخارج
الزجاج تكسر حدث حريق جزئي في البلكون
يعني في الشرفه والشرفه هي اصلا مصنوعه من
الخشب بشكل كبير ومن الزجاج فحتى الضرر لم
يكن كبيرا في هذا المنزل عموما في العاصمه
كيف الاصابات كان يعني تم اسقاط جميع
المسيرات لم تسقط ولا طائره لم تستهدف ولا
طائره مسيره هدفها طبعا لا ندري الاهداف
بالضبط ولكن لم تسقط اي طائره بشكل مباشر
على اي جسم او مبنى او اي من المؤسسات
الحكوميه ولا حتى المدنيه الاصابات كانت
دائما من الحطام بعض الحطام الطائرات سقطت
على الطريق في الاسفل بعد الضرر بعضها سقط
على صهريج للوقود وحتى صهريج لم يحترق لان
الجزء الذي سقط لم يكن مشتعلا فقط سبب ضرر
فئه السيره كذلك هنالك خط للغاز للضغط
العالي تضرر وحدث حريق جزئي وتم السيطره
عليه مباشره من السلطات كل الاصابات في
العاصمه كيف كانت في مناطق متفرقه طبعا
ولكن لم تحدث اصابات تذكر هنالك بخمسه
اشخاص يعني اصيبوا اصابات متفاوته ونقلوا
لتلقي العلاج لذلك لم تكن هنالك اصابه
مباشره على اي جسم من اجسام سواء البنيه
تحتيها وغيرها واوكرانيا كيف ستستقبل عيد
النصر وماذا عن البرلمان هل سيبرر كما قال
زيلينس كتغيير التوقيت او لا او التاريخ
بالاحرى
هذا ما تيوقع يعني هذا ما يتوقعه الجميع
يتوقعون ان يوافق البرلمان على مشروع
القانون الذي قدمه للبرلمان بتغيير تاريخ
الاحتفال من التاسع الى الثامن وطبعا هذا
ليس في هذا العام وانما في العام القادم
ان تبدا هذه العمليه اما من العام القادم
او حتى بعض النصر كما يقولون انه يمكن ان
تدخل هذه القوانين موضع التنفيذ بعد
استعاده السيطره الكامله واعلان النصر ثم
بعد ذلك يمكن ذلك ولكن بشكل عام ميسون اذا
سمحت لي فقط اشير يعني لانه في العام
الماضي توقع الناس ان يكون هنالك هجمه في
التاسع من ماي ولم تكن هنالك من الاتحاد
الروسي ولكن الناس ايضا منقسمون في
الاحتفال بعيد النصر هنالك طبعا كبار السن
الذين شاركوا في الحرب العالميه هنالك من
لديهم في عائلاتهم من شاركوا لديهم من
ابطال في الحرب العالميه لذلك هم يخرجون
ويضعون الورود ويذهبون حيث الشعله
طوال العام او المضيئه ويقدمون الورود
ويحيون الذكرى والبعض منهم يعتقد خاصه
الشباب يعني يعتقدون ان هذا العيد ليس
عيده ويجب تغييره الى التوقيت الاوروبي
كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا
لك
طبعا بالحديث عن الهجمات الروسيه على
اوكرانيا يبدو ان روسيا تستعد وبشكل مختلف
لما عرف بالهجوم الاوكراني المضاد فوفقا
لصحيفه التليجراف فان موسكو لديها سلاح
جديد قد يغير مسار الحرب وقد يجبرك على
اعاده تسوق خطتها للهجوم المضاد هذا
السلاح هو القنابل الانزلاقيه او قنابل
التخطيط هي قنابل جويه مجنحه ارخص ثمنا
واسهل في الانتاج من الصواريخ البالستيه
وايضا صواريخ كلوز امتدادها وامتلاكها
للاجنحه يمنحها مرونه ويسمح لها بالتحليق
على ارتفاعات منخفضه اضافه الى صغر حجمها
الذي يجعل امكانيه رصدها بواسطه وسائل
الدفاع الجويه التقليديه غايه في الصعوبه
طبعا هذه النوعيه من القنابل التكتيكيه
مجهزه بانظمه التوجيه والملاحه بالقصور
الذاتي والاقمار الصناعيه ما يسمح لها
بتحديد مسار رحلتها تجاه الاهداف
بم قد يصل الى 120 كم يمكن لهذه القنابل
تدمير اي هدف على مدار عشره امتار سواء
كان الهدف متحرك او ثابت المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون افادوا بان الطائرات الروسيه
الحربيه تلقي ما لا يقل من 20 قنبله موجهه
يوميا على المواقع الاوكرانيه ما دفع كييف
لاعاده النظر في انظمتها للدفاع الجوي وهو
ما دفعها لمطالبه الغرب بانظمه دفاع جوي
حديثه وبعيده المدى كمنظومات باتريوت على
امل وقف هذه القنابل
[موسيقى]
وفي سياق حرب التصريحات المتبادله بين كيف
وموسكو اكد المتحدث باسم الكرم اكد ان
تصريحات اوكرانيا عن استعدادها لقتل الروس
في جميع انحاء العالم تشير الى ان نظامك
ليس مجرد راع للارهاب بل منظم مباشر ومنظم
مباشر للاعمال الارهابيه بسكوف اضاف ان
بلاده ستراقب رد فعل الغرب
واشنطن حول تصريحات لرئيس الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه التي وصفها
بالارهابيه
وحاول تصعيد بين الصين والاتحاد الاوروبي
ايضا بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا للمره الاولى
وذلك منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا يبدو ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي بات يشعر بقلق من تزايد
العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه حيث ذكرت صحيفه
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتزم فرض عقوبات على
الشركات الصينيه التي تدعم اله الحرب
الروسيه فوفقا للصحيفه جرى ادراج سبع
شركات صينيه متهمه ببيع معدات يمكن ان
تستخدم في صنع الاسلحه في حزمه جديده من
العقوبات التي ستناقشها الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي خلال هذا الاسبوع تحتاج
قائمه العقوبات الى موافقه بالاجماع من
الدول الاعضاء التي يبلغ عددها سبعا
وعشرين دوله قبل ان يتم انفادها من المرجح
ان تثير هذه الخطوه خطوه الاتحاد الاوروبي
غضب بكين ففي اول رد منها قالت الصين انها
تعارض اي اجراءات تستخدم العلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه كذريعه لالحاق الضرر بها واضافت
انها ستتخذ اجراءات صارمه لحمايه مصالحها
اذا ما دخلت هذه العقوبات حيز التنفيذ
وتجنب الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى الان استهداف
الصين بحجه انه لا يوجد دليل يظهر انها
كانت تزود موسكو بالاسلحه بشكل مباشر
تعارض الصين بشده العقوبات غير القانونيه
التي تستهدف التعاون الصيني الروسي نحط
الاتحاد الاوروبي على عدم اتخاذ المسار
الخطا لان بكين ستدافع بحزم عن حقوقها
ومصالحها التعاون الاقتصادي بين الصين
وروسيا مشروع ولا يستهدف اي طرف ثالث
وفيما يتعلق بقضيه اوكرانيا تمسكت الصين
دائما بموقف موضوعي ولعبنا دورا بناء في
الحل السياسي للازمه
المزيد معنا من بروكسل الميراث العربيه
نور الدين الفريدي اهلا بك نور الدين
المزيد حول هذه العقوبات خاصه واننا لا
نتحدث فقط عن الصين ولكن ايضا عن دول
ثالثه يقال بانها تتحايل على العقوبات
ماذا نتوقع يوم الاربعاء
اهلا ميسون في منتصف هذا الاسبوع امام
مندوبيه دول الاعضاء السبعه والعشرين
خطه من مئات الصفحات تشمل الادله تشمل
ايضا قوائم المنتجات التي تمكن الاتحاد
الاوروبي من خلال اجهزه الاستخبارات
والادارات التجاريه من رصد ان هناك منتجات
كثيره جدا وهامه جدا تصدر من الاتحاد
الاوروبي نحو بلدان اسيا الوسطى بدلا من
تركيا حتى كازاخستان اوزباكستان
والصين وكذلك دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده حسب موارده في الوثيق الرسمي الذي
تم تسريب جزء من قليل منها
هات المنتجات يعاد تسطيرها الى روسيا هناك
يبدو ان المهندسين الروس يفككون هذه
الالات يستخدمون يستخرجون منها الرقائق
الالكترونيه ثم يعيدون استخدامها في اغراض
السلاح كيف يتم التوصل لذلك الخبراء في
الميدان وخاصه الاوكرانيين ومن معهم من
الاوروبيين يجمعون حطام هذه الصواريخ
والمسيرات والانظمه الالكترونيه التي تسقط
في ميدان اوكرانيا يبحثون هذه الادله
عندما يجدون صله بين هذا المقطع وشركه
اوروبيه او شركه امريكيه فانهم يبلغون
طبعا الاتحاد الاوروبي او الولايات
المتحده من هنا فان هذه الحزمه الجديده
التي تبحثها الدول الاعضاء بدءا من منتصف
هذا هذا الاسبوع تشمل 15 شركه اجنبيه
ثمانيه من الصين وهونج كونج وايضا شركه من
واثنتين من دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
وشركه من ايران وفي كلمه اخيره لاحظ
الاوروبيون على سبيل المثال على سبيل
المثال ان واردات كازاخستان من الات
الغسيل والثلاجات الاوروبيه قد ارتفع بين
الستين وثمانين بالمائه في غضون اقل من
عام يعني ما جعل الاوروبيين يشكون بعثوا
مع الجانب الكازاخي هذا هذا الجانب اين
تذهب هذه الالات تذهب بنسبه الاوروبيين
نحو صناعات الروسيه في ظل هذه المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه نور الدين هل نتوقع اجماع
من قبل الدول وان لم يكن كذلك طبيعه
النقاش الذي سيدار طبيعه المعوقات
في هذه المرحله العقوبات لا تزال في مستوى
النقاشات التقنيه وبالتالي مقارنه الادله
بين الدول الاعضاء ثم هناك جوانب قانونيه
لان المنتوج عند يكون منتوجا صينيا او
اوروبيا عندما تكون نسبه هذا المنتوج 60%
هناك قواعد منشا يجب الاعتماد عليها من
الناحيه القانونيه من هنا تاتي تعقيدات
النقاشات على مستوى الطاوله الاوروبيه
ولكن عموما
وصل يعني اتخذ الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات
مثلا ضد شركتين من تركيا هاتي شركتان
تستوردان معدات الكترونيه من الولايات
المتحده ومن اوروبا ثم تصدر هذه المعدات
الى روسيا ربما
ليس ربما وانما هناك اصرار اوروبي على
التوجه نوهات الدول في محاوله سد الثغرات
والاختراقات في انظمه العقوبات الاوروبيه
لان الات حاد الاوروبي يلاحظ ان العالم
وخاصه ما يسمى الجنوب الكبير او الجنوب
الساوث لا يساند الدول الغربيه في
مقارباتها ازاءه الحرب تفضل من بروكسيل
الميراث العربيه نور الدين الفريدي شكرا
جزيلا لك
وفي صراع صيني اخر لكن هذه المره مع
بواشنطن طالبت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
طلبت الولايات المتحده باحترامي سياده
بكين وامنها والعوده الى العقلانيه بحسب
تعبيرها لضمان تحقيق النجاح المتبادل في
تنميه تنميه افضل للبلدين
يجب ان لا تتحدث الولايات المتحده عن
قنوات الاتصال والحوار من ناحيه بينما
تقوم بقمع الصين من ناحيه اخرى على
الولايات المتحده احترام الصين وعدم تجاوز
الخطوط الحمر عليها التوقف عن الاضرار
بسياده الصين وامنها ومصالحها التنمويه
وعلى وجه الخصوص التعامل بشكل صحيح مع
قضيه تايوان
ماتت الاتحاد الاوروبي في اسرائيل حفله
استقبال دبلوماسي بمناسبه يوم اوروبا وذلك
بسبب المشاركه المزمعه لوزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي المنتمي لاقصى اليمين كثير
واوضح الوفد عبر حسابها على تويتر ان
البعثه قررت الغاء الاستقبال الدبلوماسي
لانها لا تريد توفير منبر لشخص تتعارض
ارائه مع القيم التي يمثلها الاتحاد
الاوروبي
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
ناسها تنجح في اطلاق قمرين اصطناعيين
لمراقبه الاعاصير والحد من تداعيات
الكوارث الطبيعيه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعلن وزير
العدل التركي عن اعتقال 13 شخصا بتهمه
اثاره اعمال العنف تجمع للمعارضه في
الدروم التركيه قال الوزير ان 200 متظاهر
القوا الحجاره اثناء خطاب لاكرم امام
اوغلو رئيسي بلديه اسطنبول والذي كان
يتحدث بالنيابه عن كمالك الاشجار اوغلو
مرشح المعارضه للرئاسه اماموجلو اثناء
حديثه اكد ان الشرطه التركيه ومؤيدي
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان سمحوا
باستمرار الهجوم
كنا نتحدث الى مواطني ارد روم كما نفعل في
كل مكان ثم نرى الحجاره تمطر علينا في كل
مكان وهناك صور بلا منازع ان الشرطه لم
تحرك ساكنا كانت هذه اوامر تلقوها وكانت
هذه اوامر لا يمكن ان يكون اي شيء اخر
كانت هناك اوامر بعدم التدخل وهناك خراطيم
مياه لكن الحجاره كانت تلقى على رؤوس
الناس كان علينا الصعود فوق الحافله وكنا
نرجم بالحجاره ويمكنك ان ترى حجم الحجاره
من الصور اوقفت حديثي بعد خمس دقائق من
ذلك الحدث لان الحجاره التي تم رمزها كانت
تتطاير فوق رؤوسنا
وتضرب الناس في الراس والعينين اصيب عشره
الى 15 شخصا امام عين مباشره
[موسيقى]
فراس جيرية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا في الوقت الذي تتجه فيه الانظار الى
تركيا طبعا قبيله الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في نهايه الاسبوع يحشد
اردوغان انصره على امل تجاوز الاختبار
الاهم في مسيرته السياسيه تظهر احدث
استطلاعات الراي ان كمالك طبعا هو منافس
اردوغان اللدود يتقدم عليه مستغلا ازمه
غلاء المعيشه الناجمه عن التضخم اضافه الى
طريقه التعامل مع الزلزال المدمر كما انه
يتقدم مستغلا السجال الذي اثير مؤخرا حول
توجهات الناخبين الشباب الذين يمثلون خمسه
ملايين ناخب وان نسبه كبيره من هؤلاء
الناخبين الجدد تعارض نظام الحكم الذي
ينتهجه اردوغان تتحضر المعارضه لالغاء
الكثير من السياسات التي اتسم بها حكم
اردوغان حاله ما فازت المعارضه تعهدت
باعاده الاستقلال للبنك المركزي وايضا
الغاء سياسات اردوغان الاقتصاديه غير
التقليديه المعارضه تعتزم ايضا العوده
للنظام البرلماني السابق فضلا عن ارسال
اللاجئين السوريين الى بلدهم كما تهدف
الاحزاب الى تحسين العلاقات مع الحلفاء
الغربيين بمفاد ذلك الولايات المتحده ستظل
كيفيه حشد المعارضه لتاييد الاكراد الذين
يمثلون 15% من الناخبين نقطه مفصليه
فبالرغم من ان حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المؤيد للاكراد ليس جزءا من تحالف
المعارضه الا انه يعارض اردوغان بعد حمله
قمع استهدفت اعضائه
مثل العديد من الشباب موقفي ليس سياسيا من
الانتخابات والسياسه ورغم ذلك عندما انظر
اليها الان فان وعود حزب الشعب الجمهوري
وكليتشاردلو تجذبني اعتقد انه يمكن
استعاده الحقوق واعاده تشكيل العداله
بالاضافه الى ذلك فان الاشياء التي يعد
بها كليتشار اوغلو خلال البث المباشر على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي حول الفئات
المحرومه تثير اعجاب حقا
اعتقد ان الشباب لديه الفرصه لتغيير
الامور اعتقد ان الكثير منهم يفكرون بنفس
الطريقه وكما تعلم فالتعليم والاقتصاد
بحاله سيئه في بلدنا الناخبون الشباب
يمكنهم منع تدهور هذه الامور بخبرتهم
وتجاربهم فالجيل القادم قادر على فعل ذلك
[موسيقى]
بالطبع اريد ان تستمر الحكومه الحاليه
نريدهم ان يستمروا باجراء بعض التغييرات
في بعض المسؤولين والسياسات وبالنظر الى
ادائه الحالي لا اعتقد ان حزب المعارضه
يمكنه تجاوز ذلك برايه اذا غيرت الحكومه
الحاليه بعض السياساتها خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالشباب والتعليم والاعمال وفرص الامل
فنحن نود الاستمرار في ظل حكم الحكومه
الحاليه
المزيد ينضم الينا من اسطنبول مراسل
العربيه زيدان زنجلو اهلا بك زيدان انقل
لنا الاجواء من عندك
نعم ميسون نحن نتواجد في ميدان بكركو
ميدان الحريه ميدانيه في وسط
اسطنبول هذه المنطقه بلديه بكركوي تتبع
للمعاضه التركيه بطبيعه الحال لكن هنا في
هذا المكان المزدحم بالسكان كما تشاهدين
كل الاحزاب الانتخابيه او كل الاحزاب
السياسيه عفوا وضعت نقاط
يداوم فيها بشكل يومي عشرات المتطوعين
يحاولون اقناع الناخبين في الايام الاخيره
بالتصويت لمرشحهم على هذا الجانب بحيث حيث
ترصد الكاميرا هذا هذه هي الاماكن او
النقاط الانتخابيه للاحزاب التي تشكل
تحالف الشعب وهو الائتلاف الحاكم حزب
الحركه القوميه بجانبه ايضا حزب العداله
والتنميه وايضا حزب
الرفاه الجديد وايضا حزب الاتحاد الكبير
على الطرف المقابل ساحاول رصد المشهد مع
زميلي المصور
ائتلاف او ائتلاف المعارضه الرئيسي وهو
تحالف الامه هنا في اقصى الزاويه ايضا
نشاهد تحالف العمل والحريه ايضا حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي باضافه الاحزاب
اليساريه المتحالفه معه ايضا حزب الشعب
الجمهوري من تحالف الامه وحزب
الديمقراطيه والتقدم بزعامه علي بابا جان
وايضا حزب الخير ميرا لبزعامه ميرال اكشنر
كل هذه النقاط النقاط الانتخابيه فيها
متطوعين وممثلين عن الاحزاب السياسيه
يوزعون
البروشورات وايضا الكتيبات التعريفيه
بالمرشحين سواء للبرلمان او للرئاسه مع
البرامج الانتخابيه لكل هؤلاء
المنافسه والايام الاخير
لكما تشاهدين يعني سنحاول الان ان ننتقل
الى بعض لو سمحت يا حزب الشعب هناك في حزب
الشعب مثلا نشاهد بعض الاشخاص قد توقفوا
للاستماع الى الممثلين او المندوبين
الموجودين هناك ايضا هنا على الطرف
المقابل ايضا عند النقطه الخاصه بحزب
العداله والتنميه ايضا هناك اشخاص يحاولون
السماع ايضا تتحرك الكاميرا الى هناك الى
الجهه المقابله ايضا هناك اشخاص يسمعون من
ممثلين المتواجدين عن حزب العداله
والتنميه هنا الى البرامج الانتخابيه
لمرشحي البرلمان عن مدينه اسطنبول وايضا
ايضا بالتاكيد البرنامج الانتخابي للرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان كما قلت هي الايام
الاخيره كل الاحزاب
استنفرت كامل قوتها للتاثير تحديدا هناك
فئه قد اتخذت قرارها وهي الفئات المؤيده
بشكل طبيعي لهذه الاحزاب
او نستطيع ان نقول الفئات المؤدلجه والتي
تنتمي الى هذه الاحزاب سواء بشكل تقليدي
او بشكل طبيعي تحاول تؤيد هذا الحزب منذ
زمن طويل لكن هناك فئه متردده ميسون تحاول
الان كل الاحزاب تركيز الجهود على هذه
الفئه المتردده قبل ايام فقط من موعد
الانتخابات الذي سيصادف يوم الاحد القادم
وهو الرابع عشر من مايو من اسطنبول مراسل
العربيه زيدان زنكلو شكرا جزيلا لك اطلقت
شركه روكت لاب الامريكيه بنجاح اول دفعه
من اقمار صناعيه تابعه لوكاله ناسا
لمراقبه تطور الاعاصير ساعه بساعه ويمكن
للمعلومات التي تجمعها الاقمار الصناعيه
الجديده ان تساعد في تحسين التوقعات
الجويه والمساعده في عمليات الاجلاء
المحتمله للسكان
ولتفادي عواقب الاعاصير المدمره كاعصار
يان الذي اجتاح فلوريدا العام الماضي
وتسبب بخسائر تجاوزت قيمه الخسائر المئه
مليار دولار
انتهت الخامسه شكرا متابعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات